Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Tyler's tackling some of the biggest questions that we receive
This question is always a very serious one. What if it's the testicized?
What if my cancer isn't just stage one anymore? What if they told me at stage four? What if I'm already in hospice?
What if my mom is laying in a hospital bed in the middle of the living room?
Is there still hope? That's a great question
So the question really is can I still get care?
So the answer is yes, so
Understand from a from a natural perspective. We're treating the patient. We're not treating cancer
So even if the cancer has metastasized our protocol. Yes, it's going to look a little bit different that if you're in stage one
We may be a little more aggressive, but the right frequencies will still work. They're going to go across your whole body
So it's not just specific to that one location
So if you have breast cancer that's metastasized to the liver and the lungs, it's still breast cancer in the liver and the lungs
It's not liver cancer and lung cancer
It's still that those breast cancer cells that have metastasized through
Circulated to ourselves to a different part of the body. So when we use right frequencies or we use nutrition
We're using diet. It's still going to affect that cancer anywhere in the body
So you don't need to worry. What we're going to be doing is going to be hitting that cancer and stimulating your immune system
So your body will help attack that cancer no matter where it is. So yes, you can still get carried. Yes, it still does work
Just a side note
The majority of people that come to us are stage four and again, we're not oncologists. We're not treating cancer
We're treating the patient. I wish more people found out they had cancer and then they decide to do an alternative
Protocol maybe along with conventional medicine as well, but but most people don't and I know some people just got diagnosed with cancer
It's already in a later stage and they're searching for help. We want to help people wherever they are
We also tell people don't ever get my hope. We've had patients stage four cancer that were given two weeks to live live years longer
Everything we do is at magic. We're trusting God in all our decision making process literally we're praying over
our cheek swabs and testing before we do any of it
So you can always still get care you always still have hope
Does alternative care still work in later stages? Yes
It can
So when you strengthen the body and you strengthen yourselves
It's always going to be better than if you are just doing standards of care or you're just trying to manage
The things that got you to where you're at right now we have to make some changes
We need to support your body to build it back up to be able to heal your body
And certainly I would never try treating cancer without the use of a rife machine
What's your success rate? That's a common question we get
Unfortunately, it's not a question. We can answer. There's legal guidelines that we have to follow
We're not treating cancer. We're not keeping success rates
And I know everybody wants to know I don't want to do anything unless there's what what's the chance of this working
The only honest answer to that is I don't know
We are in God's hands. I believe my days were numbered before the foundations of the earth were set
It's by responsibility to do everything I possibly can
But I don't know what is going to work and what's not going to work
We just have to do everything we possibly can
Bottom line is there still hope that's really what everybody are looking for there is a lot of hope
Do not believe what if somebody told you a timeline you just have to get that out of your head. You just gotta
Just you race that ask for God to erase that from your mind
There's always hope he's sovereign over all things and he knows what's going on
And we need to just follow him
And that's really what we ask our patients to do. Pray about whether this is the right thing for you
Know that we're going to be praying for you no matter what decision you make even if you don't come here
There's always hope we just got to put our hope in the right place